well it was a Medina no I was a Medina
the explosion that happened oh are you
talking about during Ramadan yeah during
Ramadan yeah
a lot of times they get turned out
because they keep associating so I just
hit you with this that violence with
Islam and they can't get past that so
before we can even get to a lot of these
commonalities and clearing these other
misconcept comparative religion some
people keep thinking no I don't want to
turn off these Muslims they're all
terrorists you know Isis they what do
you say about that you know this is the
thing that's just kind of annoying to us
as Muslims is that any Muslim does
anything and he's his religion is
mentioned you know I mean he commits a
any kind of a crime and it's like you
know this Muslim did that but you know
any Christian does anything yeah serial
killing a a schoolyard shooting you know
anything like that and they put in
totally different terms they say oh he
went postal or you know the guy was
psychologically disturbed or whatever
and they never mentioned the religion I
mean look 9/11 did not you know the the
official story it did not even answer
how building number seven came down okay
the greatest mystery of 9/11 how does a
complete building come down wasn't
wasn't touched by the air it wasn't hit
by the airplanes okay had a couple of
minor little fires of it inside it from
debris that you know was scattered into
it and you just look at it and just one
moment it drops to the ground in the
perfect picture of controlled
demolitions okay
now I'm just saying that I'm not the
only one who's looked at that and just
said yeah something's wrong
number two is you know there's been this
growing movement that questions
brand-new poll that show that more and
more Americans are rethinking what
happened on 9/11 and increasingly
more people are saying they do not
believe the government's version of
events like when you hear the fireman
they say it does not have exercise did
did not commit black flag operations did
not have what is it called extraordinary
rendition you know did not have the CIA
with the box of dirty tricks overseas
and so on and so forth you know I mean
just it's just a it's just a way of
making you look bad or silent silencing
you for having an open mind they you
don't it's a family member officially
yeah the family members I'm a family
member trying to find out the answers to
the murder of three thousand-plus people
please Architects and engineers people
all around the world scientists all
around the world are questioning this
scientists politicians former
presidential candidates took some kind
of consciousness-raising on my part
before I was willing to look at the
possibilities and really you need to go
for the evidence leads as an engineer I
have three degrees in engineering I
signed that petition for architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth some time ago
because the American people absolutely
need the truth of 9/11 look at the
evidence in fact I'll say this very
categorically any reasonable person who
looks at the evidence that's been
brought forward that's got to come away
with the feeling that something has to
be done a real investigation has to be
put forward if you can watch that video
and not have your convictions change
regarding how 9/11 happened then you
just kind of you need to get an EEG you
know an EEG an electro cephalo gram
something to check your brainwaves I
mean if you can watch that that
documentary and walk away with the
conviction that that you came in with
something's just wrong
[Music]